uh ladies and gentlemen my first guest
is known for his subtle work on the nbc
show will and grace
please welcome sean hayes
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
thank you sean
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah that was very
how can i nice you here
you're not coming out of this here we go
wait wait wait ah
very nicely done nicely done graceful
sean that was incredible thank you so
much sean that was
that was many things that was dramatic
that was expensive
it also looked incredibly uncomfortable
it was uh
it was i'm kind of i just want to know
the uh let you know the extra mile that
i went for you for that bit
that's nice i had my testicles
surgically removed
nice and um so we have something in
common yes
and i just want to show you something no
no no no no no no no
you are now looking at the at the inside
of my body
that's that's what i did for you what
did you do for me that's your own part
now let's
let's talk there's something important
you you are from chicago
actually
you're a local boy aren't you yeah
you know that's what you would that yeah
yeah that's what you would think i'm
actually from trenton
no you bastard you laugh oh come on
[Music]
no no no no come back come back
no no i'm from uh suburbs i'm from glen
island but i was hung out downtown
[Applause]
[Music]
whatever they are that's sad one person
in the audience just was like meow
i'm glenn allen yeah now you were you
were weren't you in a band here you were
in a band yeah yeah um sounds from the
stairs
exactly exactly in the business we call
that pity applause
um you got a lot of that
[Applause]
i licked the snow globe and now i have
super powers
so uh yeah i wasn't i was in a band that
uh clearly nobody's ever heard of yes
and i was in it for five years right
right out of college and uh
you know i i played keyboards which you
know like
like the the guitar is always very very
sexy instruments playing the drums like
the twirl the thing you know right right
right right like but
you can really like on the guitar you
can rock and you can make an extension
of your penis the guitar
thank you but the true but the keyboards
the keyboards
scott how does scott feel
[Applause]
you know what there we go
more pity applause you know what's uh
that guy's uh
not in therapy at all yeah i know now
scott's going to be waiting for that guy
after the show he's going to be looking
through 3 800 people who where is he
going that guy's gonna have a guitar
going dude you want to start a band
so uh no uh but you know there's nothing
sexy about playing the keyboard so i'd
sit there and think like i was all cool
like everybody be in front i'd be like
[Music]
[Laughter]
you can't win doing that no no it's
horrible you have to compensate by like
shaking the ass a lot and moving around
oh maybe you do i don't yeah yeah okay
that's nice do you miss this town do you
miss living in this town
i do you know the thing that i miss most
about this this time of year in this
town are barbecues because the food is
the best in the world here right now
uh it's true yeah
it's true and there's like nine
barbecues going on in the studio right
now
up there these people are just cooking a
whole pig up there
they're just slowly
yeah yeah um no but uh uh yeah growing
up
with the barbecues and stuff and like
the thing i never understood as a kid
was people be like hey come over for a
barbecue it'd be like great
it'd be like bring something to grill
and something you like to drink
and your favorite side and it's like
well i mean would you want us you want
me to bring the grill too or
and maybe build the deck to grill it on
but but i thought maybe i could use this
to my advantage
out of college so i i just constantly
because i had no money
right out of college i'd constantly have
all these barbecues and have bring
people bring all the food and i'd have
groceries
for four weeks yeah yeah it's something
good it's take advantage of people it
seems like that's the lesson you're
teaching us here
yes wow you're a really bad guy
have you uh what do you do to screw with
your friends
just get their credit card numbers and
screw around i'm more high-tech i'm like
i'll destroy you
there do it i'm not into just taking
food all right you know we got to take a
break
we will have more officer sean hayes in
just a minute